the White House is focusing on Supreme
Court nominee Brett Kavanaugh Senate
confirmation hearing which starts
tomorrow some of the speakers at Senator
McCain's funeral on Saturday seem to
have the President on their mind so did
a handful of protesters who lined the
streets outside the president's Virginia
Golf Club yesterday Paula Reed is at the
White House Paula good morning good
morning it was a weekend of mourning
here in Washington as Senator John
McCain was laid to rest
but as McCain was being eulogized by the
political establishment President Trump
kept a low profile engaging in a
familiar weekend routine tweeting at his
political adversaries and playing golf
president Trump headed back to his Golf
Club Sunday CNN cameras captured him
there Saturday as well less than 20
miles away at the memorial service for
John McCain mr. Trump's impact on
American democracy and his favorite
political slogan were under fire the
America of John McCain has no need to be
made great again because America was
always great Megan McCain the late
senator's daughter took aim without
naming mr. Trump we gather here to mourn
the passing of American greatness the
real thing not cheap rhetoric from men
who will never come near the sacrifice
he gave so willingly the president
appeared to fire back on Twitter
Saturday evening with a simple make
America great again she is her father's
daughter
South Carolina Republican Lindsey Graham
a confidant of McCain's but also a
friend of the president defended ms
McCain if you say something about about
her dad you will know it whether you the
janitor the president noted States
former presidents Barack Obama and
George W Bush each took indirect shots
at the president's approach to governing
it's a politics that pretends to be
brave and tough but in fact is born of
fear john de tested the abuse of power
could not abide bigots and swaggering
despots speakers at the service also
spoke of bipartisanship and putting
country over party and this week's
confirmation hearings for Supreme Court
justice nominee Brett Kavanaugh will
certainly serve as a test to whether or
not lawmakers and attendants took that
sentiment to heart Anthony
Thanks